now just because so many people asked me
about it before what does that say that
says the absolute value of L and X which
is really just a lazy way of saying log
base e of X does anyone know why it's an
M general not the end stands for it says
for natural because what you're thinking
about logs right the natural base to use
is e okay why e 2.7 1 blah blah blah
we'll dig into that a little further
when we get to Exponential's and larges
follow in topic but suffice to say at
the moment the real kind of work with
logs and functions all this invasive
okay we're only starting off with like
base to base for base 8 because you can
do the mental arithmetic on those okay
you can work out what log base 2 of 8 is
because through the power of something
equals 8 you can work out the numbers on
that but this is some irrational awful
mess right but it's where all the
interesting maths comes from anyhow what
does this thing look like well think
about it without your absolute value
signs on it okay there you go
okay in fact it's a mirror image I'll
just draw it in it's a mirror image of e
to the X okay if you turn your head 45
degrees if you put y equals x in there
it's an exact reflection across we'll
talk a little more about that when we go
into inverse functions okay but the
reason why I draw this out is because
with the Newman EDX we know it has an
asymptote it has an asymptote where it
has an asymptote at y equals zero again
habit of asymptotes on lines they're not
points or values right so y equals zero
is a completely different asymptote from
x equals zero so don't say zero say what
the asymptote if this guy has an
asymptote of y equals zero then this guy
will have an asymptote of x equals zero
which is the actual what I'm interested
okay so I'm approaching the y-axis in
there
just like I have a white assets here of
one I'll have an x-intercept here also
of one right so now I have all my
critical points and now I apply my
absolute notes ok I clearly have this
part over here greater than one which is
all fine happy times ok but then I have
this part of the graph that's negative
right so what do I do with it it flips
us it flips up ok so it's going to do
this and approach the same asymptote
right because if I flip over x equals
zero vertically it's still x equals zero
for rent so there's your graph you don't
even have to move the axis
yes now when you get to this one and
this is actually a critically important
function for us it's not just I'm
putting absolute value science or
wherever I want this actually comes up
when we look at the topic of integration
so just make a mental mark when we get
to that this guy will appear what does
this mean what is me I'm gonna refer
back to like the algebraic idea of what
happens when you plant absolute values
okay
I say when X is less than zero when X is
less than zero what's this thing equal
to Y should be equal log off now I'm
taking the negative K sana so it's log
of negative X right and then when X is
positive I just have regular log X
that's the positive case okay hold on a
second this is a bit interesting right
come back over here why is it that the
holograph doesn't appear on this side of
the Cartesian plane y doesn't appear
here now because
good it never gets there but in addition
to that I mean we know other functions
just to play devil's advocate
we know other functions that do this but
they do cross on the other side for
example one on X it does that has an
asymptote in the middle but he has no
problem appearing on the other side of
the asymptote right but log X does
why doesn't log X ever cross over to the
side yeah I check this okay let's think
about this right let me come back to
this guy right because you think I can
numerically do this right suppose I put
in this okay now we then posed the
question what does this mean this means
tell me the number that when I raised to
to that power whatever number you're
thinking of I get negative eight and
there isn't a real number that does that
right
you can put an astronomically large
numbers through to the 10 to the 100 and
you just get really big numbers you
could put a really small numbers really
negative numbers like 2 to the negative
10 to the negative 100 and all you get
is really is really small numbers but
you never get negatives right you never
you never cross over to the negative x
right uh-huh
unless you do this thing all right
what does this mean what does it mean
when you have a negative sign over there
yeah kind of okay so thing about this
think of an example let's take x equals
its natural log okay so negative in okay
everything has to be in YZ otherwise my
numbers are going to be disastrous when
x equals negative me I'm in this domain
okay so this law applies not this one
right so Y will equal to log of negative
negative E right which is log of E which
if you can case you can remember it's
log base C of E which means what's the
number then I raise e to in order to get
eaten the answer is 1 ok so hold on a
second we were just saying walls don't
make sense
over here but they do if you slap an
absolute now you sound like you think
back to definition 1 it means absolute
value sign means take the positive right
so that means you'll always get
something sensible even if you start
with something that shouldn't make sense
the absolute value will make it make
sense ok so if I were to graph these if
I put them all together okay you're
gonna have your regular log graph see
within X is written regular zero you got
a regular old log X but when you look at
values to the left of the axis you're
gonna get the same thing just over there
all right one negative one okay
that's an interesting case think about
that guy right x equals negative 1 it'll
be sorry it'll be this case right so
it's gonna be log off negative negative
1 which is log of 1 and what's the
number but if you raise e to that you'll
get 1 the answer is 0 and that's why
it's an intercept ok so a plane absolute
value sign gives you this function it
gives its symmetry just like just like
the original absolute value of x also
tastes in
it's the same symmetry because it's in
there right